Fellas! I'm getting married.
It’s going to be just like old times.
Only better, right?
Better.
Hollywood has come a-calling.
They want to make
“Unfinished Business” into a movie.
Our carefree college days on full display.
I love it.
That book caused a lot of drama.
Get your popcorn ready.
Oooooo.
You need a change of scenery.
Come with us to Quentin’s wedding.
It’s guaranteed to put
a smile on your face.
You need to find something
you're passionate about.
Redefine your purpose!
I thought you found your purpose
with that perfume commercial.
Always...in my playbook.
Always in my playbook.
Aw, wait. I’m sorry.
We all make mistakes.
And you've got to live
with the consequences.
I know what it's like to be a tired,
overworked, exhausted mom.
Wait, don't you have, like, three nannies?
It takes a village.
Life doesn’t always go the way we expect.
But if we're lucky,
we end up where we're supposed to.
We're actually really looking forward
to some husband and wife time.
Yes, we are.
Are you two going to have sex?
What’s sex?
A really yummy dessert.
Oooo, then can I have sex?
Okay.
Do you know who I want to play me?
-Who?
-Beyoncé.
Get your coins together, brother.